david bennett had been given six months
to live and didn't qualify to receive a
human heart doctors told him there was
no guarantee he'd survived receiving a
heart transplanted from a pig this
patient
was given an opportunity for this
this experimental transplant with the
idea of mind that we didn't know
what the outcome might be but it wasn't
going to be worse than traditional
therapy a gene-edited pig heart was used
to reduce the risk of the patient's body
rejecting the organ
and three days after surgery doctors say
he's doing well bennett's son says his
father is glad he made the difficult
decision he realizes
the magnitude of what was done
um and he really realizes the importance
of it um and talking with him um
i've never in my life um
heard or seen my dad cry but i think he
realized the the seriousness of his
condition in the last couple weeks
decades of research went into the
medical breakthrough it was always said
that xenotransplantation
is the future and always will be this
was quoted multiple times i would like
to say that xenotransplantation is now
the present
in the united states alone an estimated
10 000 people die every year waiting for
a transplant it's one of the reasons
says cautious excitement it's
significant because we don't have
a source of human organ replacement
of sufficient
numbers
to answer demand
and not only demand but a timely demand
but for now david bennett and his family
have been thrown a lifeline barbara
angopa al jazeera